hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer
i provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers
and today we're going to be talking
about github
readme now if this is not your first
video you know make sure you hit that
subscribe button it really helps me out
really helps support my channel
and so also make sure you follow me on
instagram you can engage with me more
there and so
yeah let's just build this community now
the github
project we're going to be working with
is an old project of mine while it's
going through coding boot camp
it's called piggy for piggy bank
it was a financial literacy uh
like web app where people would track
their expenses and then see like
a chart auto populate of the proportions
of
you know their expenses going to wear
and all of that
so yeah we're going to work with that so
let's get to it so this is what our
readme is going to look like we're going
to go into
very deep detail about how to make it
look like this
but i wanted to show you what the end
result is
code examples picky features
status why contact and
license
so let's scroll back up and click
on yeah click on edit
you all would have a blank like default
readme that github would have
created automatically after you create a
repo
it would have just like just default
stuff and so
you'd click this pencil
button to edit it
so right away the first thing we want to
do
is tell people what this app is what is
the title of your app
and you know make that the first thing
they see and so we do that in github by
putting this you know hashtag pound
symbol
um and then followed by a space and then
the title you want your audience to see
so for me that was piggy web app front
end
i've also done it where it's just the
name of the app and front end
i always make sure it says front end or
back and because for me
i never have combined projects i make
sure that there's always
a separation of concern that's really
for me the most efficient way to develop
and so
my repos always say front end or back
end and so
there that was and then there's the
table of contents
so in github your headers start with a
pound
or one hashtag and then your sub headers
are two hashtags
and so everything else in here are two
hashtags
and the next thing i put here are the
table of contents
so that people can very quickly from the
get-go
know what to expect out of this readme
without having to parse through it all
but we're going to get back to this and
there's actually something really cool
about the table of contents which i
really like
so we're going to get back here because
for me the table of contents is always
something i do
last because it's based on the structure
of
the readme and so if i don't know the
structure yet how can i create a table
of contents i i it's no so
so i always do that last and so we'll
get back to that
but now the next thing i do
is provide an about
x and x app so about piggy and so i just
say
how piggy is an expense tracker for
users it
gives users insights as to what's in
their piggy bank by
being by providing a list breakdown of
all of the expenses they log
and it also provides users with
resources on
to better their financial literacy and
so you know it doesn't have to be
you know some wall street journal
article or anything just
something quick and just saying look
this is what this is about
because here's the thing you want
to remember that a lot of people who are
going to your github specifically
i tailor things like this to recruiters
when i'm looking
specifically for when i'm looking for a
job and recruiters don't have the time
to open the app and try it out
themselves and go into their code base
especially because a lot of recruiters
aren't engineers themselves so they
likely don't know how to deal with all
of this and so i try to just
provide them with all the information
they need
on my apps on my projects without them
actually needing to go
into the code same thing with people who
would interview you they those people
may be
engineers maybe project managers so they
may have you know the better abilities
to actually go through your code and
things like that
but still odds are they won't so just
provide them with something easy to look
at
and just see what you're about and so on
that theme the next thing i would always
provide
was a walkthrough video of my app i
would film the walkthrough the same way
i'm doing here
just putting you know quicktime player
screen record
and hitting play and i would really just
the video was always just me using it i
wouldn't really
explain um like the technologies i used
i wouldn't
i wouldn't really explain anything i
would just be a user
providing um and showing what the user
experience would
look like so they'd be very quick videos
one to three minutes depending on how
big
the app was so in github
the way to add you know links to certain
texts so that
it's the text that shows and not the
link but once they click on the text
they go to that link
it's by putting brackets let me do it
here
it's by putting brackets putting text
within
brackets so you can say click me if you
wanted a link
that said that and then if you wanted it
to go
to google.com
like that and that's how you do it you
would put the url within parentheses
make sure you don't have a space having
a space changes
um the ability for it to be linked so
you wouldn't put a space just back to
back and so so i can
show you what this now looks like
let's see let's zoom out a little tiny
bit
okay so you see now click me and i'm not
going to click it because we haven't
saved
certain changes and it might mess things
up so
yeah now you can say click me and you
see how there's no link being shown
or anything no um url being shown
yeah so that's something really cool
about
github that i really really like
so i use that really everywhere where
were we oh right here
so yeah you have to click me right here
but i'll take it out from now
so the next thing i do is provide
a list of technologies that i used in
creating this front-end portion or
back-end portion
depending on what portion you're on for
me it's end so defining the technologies
i used the languages i used
the frameworks i used for me this was
built in
vanilla javascript so i didn't use any
frameworks like
react angular view i didn't use any of
those it was just javascript
and so i put javascript es6 and then
html
css and i wanted to put the versions
there um just so this readme withstands
the test of time and i always know what
version i used no matter how
long time goes by you know
things like that because that affects
you know certain variables and scope and
functions and things like that what
version you use so that's why i put that
there
but yeah if i had used a framework i
also would have included you know react
and angular and things like that
but yeah i list the technology so that
the recruiter seeing this the
interviewer seeing this can can see that
i am not lying on my resume during my
interviews when i say i'm proficient
in javascript i'm proficient in angular
things like that then i go down to the
setup so the setup
this is something that um honestly it's
kind of like my
least favorite part um even though it's
so small but these
setup i use this section to just
provide people seeing um this read me
just the instructions on how to have the
project
on their local computers um to
mess around with and play around with on
their own
so they're not playing around my code no
no i don't i don't play those games
but they themselves can um
you know alter things and see how the
code really works
and things like that and really just
fostering their own learning
that is where the license at the bottom
comes up though so we'll get to that
but yes i provide setup instructions and
so i say
to run this project please go to the
backend repo
which i made sure i linked to the actual
github url all the urls here
are you know adjusted so that certain
confidential information of mine
stays confidential but yeah you would
have the full
url here that would connect to the back
end repo
of this project because yeah you for me
for this
app you needed both a back end and a
front end which were separate
then two after you follow the
instructions
on the back end repo whatever was
provided there
run light server in your front end
directory
then click here and then that was the
local host you know 2001
so they can preview the app
on their local machine instead of
looking on youtube or things like that
now i find this section so
so so so important code examples
code examples was just somewhere i put
you know some type of um
look into how i develop how i use
functions how i create you know the
functions and the variables and things
like that
and just showing like look this is yeah
what i can do and so it's a very small
of course like when it comes to
the entire project this is point zero
one percent of the entire project
but it's still nice to see that you know
the person actually
okay they can create a
iterative function they can um create
like work with
arrays and map through them and all of
that and so
i provided code examples now to provide
code examples
this is what you do you provide these
backticks so not an apostrophe like this
for me i use a macbook and so um
this backtick is under the escape
button on the top left of my keyboard
so if you're also on the macbook on the
top left of your keyboard
um it's under this kit for me so for me
it's the second button down from the top
left
that is where you put the backtick if
you can't find it
it's the same button as this like
sideways s
right here i know there's a name for it
someone comment the name
please for this i can't think of the
name but um
yeah it's the same uh button
as this sideways s but
it's the back tick portion so you do
three of the back ticks then put
example here and then you close it
out with three more backticks
and so let's see what it looks like
in preview mode so preview changes
let's zoom out and see you see how now
it has its own little section right here
the example here
yes that's why code examples um
specifically like using backticks
is important because it really shows it
as like
code with i hope if you can't see what
i'm talking about maybe
bring your brightness down a little bit
let's see can i bring my brightness down
i feel like that doesn't help anything
but yeah it creates these like little
boxes this these like super light gray
boxes
around the code so that it really
differentiates
text from code and then i had provided
different code examples two code
examples and so
it breaks them up into their own
portions and so
that's very important both for the look
and also just the functionality of this
readme
and so let's go back to the editing
of this go back to code examples
and yeah now just take that out
and so for me i wouldn't type this
in readme specifically it i would just
look through my app because
the readme was always created after the
app
was finished always um
if i if i was eager i would maybe put an
about
but really nothing else because the
thing is
you think you're creating one app and
then a month goes by and you're finished
and you realize it's a whole different
app
and so it's just better to leave things
like readmes and all of that
to the very end so that you're not in
this loop of constantly editing your
readmes and all of these
different things so anyway
yeah i would go into my code go into my
project
and find somewhere that i
liked what i put you know and i would
want it to be just a couple of lines
like five to eight lines of code
um and yeah make sure it was as
efficient as possible something
something to say like look like i write
decent
code for the level i'm in or something
like that
so then i would just copy and paste it
and then put
the backticks before before the back
ticks
after that coding section
and so i did two different examples so
that's why there's the two sets
of the backticks i hope that made sense
i
really really hope it did but no we're
just moving along here
so next we have the piggy features
this was where i provided the
reader with what to expect with this app
so input and track expenses visualize
expenses through a colored
donut chart and then provide finance and
budgeting
resources then i provided a to-do list
part of the piggy features because i
wanted to
also just show that i have plans for
this
app i i don't consider myself done i
never
with specifically app development i
never consider myself done
it's app development and just
development in general is something
that you can constantly go at over and
over
so i always provided a to-do list and
for here
it was ad expense breakdown options
labeling expense
type status completed
this app is built to carry out the
crutch framework
crud so crud stands for
create read
update delete basically
every well maybe not every app but
basically
the core of most apps is to carry out
the crud framework if you think about
facebook
instagram blogs you want to be able to
create a post
read other people's posts update your
own posts or your own um what you call
it
wall or your own you know update
pictures update any
things like that or delete pictures
delete post delete
blog posts so that's really the
base of um i say kind of every app but
i may be wrong with every but with most
apps that's the
base you always want to see so yeah i
say this app is built to carry out the
crud framework
then down here i say why i decided to
create this specific app and it's the
same thing
um i shared with you all just moments
ago
because i care about financial literacy
as a finance major myself
and so i wanted to provide a resource
for individuals to
do the same to be their best
selves when it comes to money habits and
things like that
then at the bottom here is some of the
most important portions
i would put a contact field in which
i linked my name to my linkedin so
created by
and then my name in the brackets because
i wanted it
to directly link to my linkedin and so
like my linkedin like url so it would be
like slash like
nia something like that and so
then in the actual readme they'd be just
able to click on my name it would take
them to my linkedin
then license so the license
part is what allows
other viewers other readers to
use your code to develop with your code
um
but also say like hey you can't just
steal this
or you can maybe they can and that's
okay with you i personally don't play
those games
but saying like yeah you can use this
um but at the end of the day this is my
work you can use it for your own
learning and development and things like
that but this
is my work and so the license i'm going
to have to look
um here i'll make sure to actually
provide a
link to the license because i always use
the same exact license every time
so i'll provide a link to the license in
the description box because i can't
specifically remember i think i just
searched
github license types there were three
main
types i saw um like the three most
popular ones and i chose one that i
just preferred but um yeah i'll link the
license
um down in the description box that way
it's just one less thing for you all to
do
and so yeah there we go and so then we
would
we would click commit changes i'm not
going to go all the way down because
some personal information is down there
but um i'll just go into the preview
that way you can see what it would look
like
so yeah oh shoot hold on
wait a minute i am so sorry i forgot
about the table of contents that is my
bad y'all i'm so sorry so table of
contents
so table of contents i would go in
and look at each of the sections i put
in
and in brackets place all of those
sections
here now we're talking about linking
to link to outside resources we use the
parentheses and the you know
just the url to link inside
your own readme you use a hashtag
so you do i'll draw at the bottom here
so i'll say
example oh no hold on
so i'll say example within brackets
and then right away no space or anything
right away you put parentheses
and then you say whatever the name of
that header
was so example dash header
there are no spaces allowed if there's a
space you
replace it with the dash so you see how
about piggy
has a space right here and the table of
content name is about
so to link to it
i was i put hashtag about
dash piggy then you see how underneath
it's piggy walk through video
and then but all i name it here in the
table of contents is video
so i would put hashtag piggy dash
walkthrough dash video in the
parentheses
and so if we look at the preview again
it would just be about video technology
setup
but it links to the different portions
and so if i click it i'll wait
let me get out of this so i will be
right back
hey all we're back so we have our table
of contents
let's say i want to jump right into code
examples right away
so i click code examples and it jumps
you see how the screen
jumps to that section and so now if i
scroll
back up i see all the other sections
that were before it
and i can you know go back to table of
contents if i want to jump to the
license
i click license boom jumps right
to the license the license is the last
part of the page and so that's why it's
not like up here because there's nothing
to show below that but anyway
but yeah so it jumps the license that's
why the table of contents is important
it
is just a nice efficient way of
providing the user with a more seamless
easy experience and you know we're
developers y'all like all we want to do
is provide
seamless efficient experiences to our
users and so that does
not change with readme and honestly if
you're looking at
you know companies and things like that
it's that shows them that like no you
think about the user
process first you think about their
experience first and they see that in
these examples
features piggy features boom
just so i can show you just a little bit
of the license
i think you guys would appreciate seeing
that this is what it is
so the license is a you know for me it
was like just a general license
and yeah it provides like the rights and
copyrights and
the yada yada yada so make sure you're
putting that
in your readme because if you're
building the next uber we don't want
someone
you know from down the hall who just
stumbled upon your readme
to get those millions y'all that's
important don't forget to hit that
subscribe button
i hope you liked this really
comprehensive detailed look into
creating a really nice standard readme
for your projects and yeah please let me
know if you have any questions down
below
but don't forget to follow me on
instagram at the black female engineer
and i look forward to see y'all later so
no bye all